chick-fil-a is one of the most
successful fast-food chains in the US as
they are the fifth largest in the US and
generate more revenue per restaurant
than any other chain chick-fil-a sales
have grown to over ten billion dollars
last year and they even passed KFC s two
largest chicken retailer in the US in
2013 so how did chick-fil-a even start
and how did they get so big make sure to
stick around till the end to find out
[Music]
chick-fil-a actually has its roots in
dwarfed will which established in 1946
by truth Cathy this was a small
restaurant in hatful Georgia a small
suburb of Atlanta this actually grew
into a chain and today they actually
have told locations which are called
wharf house in 1961 after 15 years in
the fast-food business Cathy actually
invented the pressure fryer which could
cook chicken in the same on time as you
could cook a hamburger
he put a chicken between two buns which
was super odd at the time but this would
eventually become a pretty popular meal
he then went down registered the name
chick-fil-a which is a play on the word
fillet and the a shows that was a plus
food he also went down and trademarked
the slogan we did invent the chicken we
just invented a chicken sandwich he then
went to open the first chick-fil-a in
1967 in green pear mall in a suburb of
Atlanta throughout the 1970s and 80s
they expanded quickly an open lot more
locations but all mainly in malls the
first free-standing location was opened
on April 16th 1986 in Atlanta Georgia
from then on she released her to focus
on standalone stores as opposed to food
court stores and since the very
beginning they always says Sundays off
as he believed that his employees and
operators should have at least one day
to rest and spend time with her family
and friends he said that he didn't want
to work on Sundays and he didn't want to
pay someone to do something that he
won't want to do himself he also thought
that this one day off really maximize
productivity during the rest of the week
since then we have expanded across the
u.s. but most of locations are in
southern suburbs there
lifetime they've only had two
international ventures which were into
Canada and South Africa in September of
1994 they opened their first location
Alex at the u.s. in the University of
Alberta in Edmonton but this store did
not perform well and in just two to
three years they closed down the store
and they wouldn't return to Canada for
two more decades in May 2014 they opened
a chick-fil-a in the Calgary
International Airport near the departure
area and just last year in July of 2018
the annoucer plants expanded to Canada
starting in Toronto over the next five
years they plan to open 15 to 20 stores
in Canada and in August of 1996 they
open their first location outside North
America in Durban South Africa they also
opened a second location in November of
1997 in Johannesburg South Africa but by
2001 both these doors were closed due to
profitability as it is clear they really
don't have any international presence
but how are they so successful within
America first of all they have a really
simple menu and their focus has remained
on chicken sandwiches they really
haven't moved that much away from their
original menu they cared more about
keeping their best-selling food high
quality and improving it if possible
then trying to add new food nothing on
their menus of poor quality and they
were very proud of every single food out
of this earth this has really helped
create great brand loyalty in America's
often associate chicken sandwiches with
chick-fil-a other fast food chains have
tried to expand and this simply distorts
a view on the restaurant when
restaurants try to do this people don't
have a clear view on why to go to
restaurant and eventually they stop
going to that restaurant and the best
example of this is KFC they were iconic
for fried chicken and people went there
to get five chicken by 1990's they tried
to move away from fried items and
chicken by introducing stuff like to
double-down and this lecture main menu
item fried chicken to suffer and quality
Azura focusing on new menu items and
people start noticing this fall on
quality nice charge associate KFC
with bad
as it is evident it is very important to
keep your main menu item of high quality
please - when people associate with your
restaurant and chick-fil-a execute that
perfectly and today there are one of the
fastest-growing restaurants they even
graved in many people's mind that if you
want a chicken sandwich you go to
chick-fil-a and that is really what
drives most of the traffic your business
model of having hands-on management has
also really led to a great success
getting a chance from our chick-fil-a is
extremely difficult like less than 1%
chance it is literally hard to become an
operator of a chick-fil-a
then attend one of the most prestigious
universities in the world and
chick-fil-a operators must complete an
extensive multi week training program as
well and finally they can take over
operation of their own location
chick-fil-a makes it very clear this is
not a passive investment they want
hands-on management it's virtually
impossible to run more than a couple of
stores which is already extremely
difficult this ensures that their
operators of each store are really
dedicated to that one location only but
they really do help you a lot during the
whole process you only have to put down
about ten thousand dollars to open a
chick-fil-a that's because they're not
looking to expand as fast as possible
with franchise applications they're
looking for great store operators who
can maintain perfect customer service
that lives up to chick-fil-a brand for
the amount of profit they generate there
you go ran out misters all over the
place without any franchises but they
don't want to do that they want to help
small franchise owners they want to
provide customers the perfect experience
they do charge a little bit more than
most fast food places but I think that
most people definitely think that it is
worth it
chick-fil-a is almost trying to have all
of your locations be local diners run by
local owners who are really dedicated to
just that one store and this is love
chick-fil-a locations to really trample
their competitors in terms of per store
sales and this business approach is one
of the key reasons that chick-fil-a is
so successful and of course they have
great customer service and this is
really promoted by their business model
when operators only have one restaurant
they really care about that one
restaurant and all the employees that
work there and this really allows
them to maintain perfect customer
service waters good to choose your own
wages for workers but is usually pretty
high compared to other faster places at
ten to twelve dollars while other
fast-food places offered just less than
ten dollars this leads to a lot more
applications and allows owners to find
the best applicant they can actually
choose someone who is dedicated and
committed and will actually stay for
quite a long time and it's not just
great customer service they also have
great maintenance of all of their
locations their cleanliness is one of
the best in the industry and this really
does to get to customers in countless
third-party studies have shown that
chick-fil-a has one of the highest
customer satisfaction rate in the
industry and this great customer service
and cleanliness really allows
chick-fil-a to have great brand loyalty
they also have great marketing I mean
who doesn't know their popular slogan
eat more chicken with misspelled more
and chicken and of course they have the
ads that show the cows only up signs and
say eat more chicken and it's not just
the marketing content but their high
integrity in January of 2004 there was a
huge mad cow disease scare and they
completely stop showing cow commercials
they thought that it was insensitive and
unfair to take advantage of such
circumstances they really believe that
they are fair and expect other people to
be fair to them as well and as a result
they vigorously protect their
intellectual rights there have been more
than thirty cases where they fight
people for using the phrase eat more
they believe that this dilutes our
distinctiveness and diminishes their
marketing power I do believe that a lot
of these cases are pretty petty but
that's a hold on a discussion in itself
they also sponsor several events across
the nation in several locations and many
stadiums as well for example they have a
store in the mercedes-benz stadium in
Atlanta but this still lands felons are
beliefs they continue to stay closed on
Sundays even though many of the games
take place on Sundays but they do break
their beliefs if they believe that
people actually need help for example on
December 17 to 2017
there was a power outage in Atlanta
Airport and distrained heard thousands
of travelers they thought they would be
best if the
to tradition and open the restaurant
Sunday nard help all these transit
passengers they're great marketing and
integrity really go a long way and the
last main thing that has helped a
company is keeping the company a private
family-owned company and not going
public before Kathy died in 2014 he
actually made his choice on a contract
that said that they would never let the
company go public they are however
allowed to sell to a private company but
they haven't done that either
the fact that they are not owned by a
corporate giant allows them to really
care about each and every customer for
example young brands has so many
successful sub brands like KFC and Taco
Bell and Pizza Hut they have so many
customers and has such a huge company
but they simply cannot care about each
individual customer and this is not
necessarily their fault this is just a
side effect of being so big chick-fil-a
has really kept to a small number of
locations even today having only 2,200
locations across the u.s. this is
nothing compared to other fast-food
chains that have similar amounts of
revenue subway has over 10 times is just
in the u.s. at 26,000 locations and
McDonald's has 13,000 locations in the
US but despite a location disadvantage
chick-fil-a has been able to remain a
strong competitor in the fast food
industry and the fact that they're a
family owned brand allows them a lot of
power to do stuff that they want that
big brands cannot I'm sure that the
sundae closures would not go down well
with public investors in February of
chief Flynn announced a day off planet
Earth Chicken nationwide I was raised
without antibiotics within 5 years other
big brands like McDonald's and KFC
simply cannot do this
these are vast size and corporate
pressure but as a private family-owned
business chick-fil-a is able to reap all
these benefits as well
the story of chick-fil-a is so
outstanding as it has such modest roots
and there are still so modest that I try
and take over the fast food industry or
expand internationally they have their
own niche food which is iconic to them
and they really stick to this I care
about each and every customer and this
is really wise a lot of them to be so
successful in the first place they stick
to what they're good at and lead based
on one
ethical beliefs creating a restaurant
chain that is truly committed to the
customer and the food this is truly an
inspirational story but that's all I
have for you guys on chick-fil-a I
should comment down below what company
you would like me to cover next also if
you guys liked this video they measure
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you like to see more videos just like
this one
until then I'm hari I'll see you guys on
the next one